sachez qu'à dispo Cyril vous avez votre
magnéto préféré de la semaine dernière
notre sourire votre discussion avec le
technicien alors on va on démarre par ça
on démarre pas ça
c'est technicien mais vous allez voir
que plus la conversation avance plus
sérieuse de secours c'est le sortez-moi
de la semaine dernière incroyable allez
c'est moi
c'est extraordinaire simple avec elle a
mordu un serpent
un rongeur avec le reste quel moment je
commence à m'en bats les couilles
[Musique]
mais vous allez voir que la conversation
avant de plus Cyril s'en bat les
couilles
voilà
parce qu'après le rongeur en fait
s'attaque au rectif
et comme dans la salive des rongeurs qui
a une espèce d'anesthésiant le reptile à
Linux vont même pas compte qu'il se fait
ranger ça peut faire de gros gros
déguste
c'est intéressant ça se voit sur ma tête
[Rires]
avec plaisir ça veut dire
les gars
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
entre la porte d'Orléans et les reptiles
[Rires]
je l'adore vraiment c'est un superbe
de tigre du Bengal à la Porte d'Italie
on va le revoir là là-bas
ça on a déjà vu mais quand un patron est
fier de ses employés qu'est-ce qu'il
fait normalement alors il lui fait un
compliment une augmentation comme je
l'ai réclamé ou encore une promotion
même avec Cyril on l'a vu les
compliments c'est un peu autre chose
c'est le patron un peu trop sympa de la
semaine c'est quoi
le patron un peu trop sympa de la
semaine
[Musique]
et bien
résister
c'est génial
d'être casting
[Musique]
j'ai dit j'ai dit c'est pour le
féliciter
ça n'a rien à voir
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que tu veux qu'il te félicite
deux fois ah pardon
[Rires]
alerte
ça veut dire je suis solaire
Daniel Daniel tu vas tu pars avec
Laurent beau cet été
non
c'est la même mais en version
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous ne comprenez pas ce que vous
chroniqueurs disent surtout quand il y a
Benjamin Castaldi mais je vous rassure
le public non plus de comprend pas c'est
le qu'est-ce qu'il dit la semaine
j'adore c'est encore castelier
de la semaine
[Musique]
Macron qui est en déplacement province
il y a quelqu'un dans la foule qui est
venu serrer la main qui pose une
question et qu'on apprenait après que la
question il la connaissait jamais le
Macron que c'était quelqu'un qui allait
lui poser il savait déjà tu serais
choqué en disant ou alors
le public n'a pas compris donc mais
heureusement les collègues de
Jean-Michel sont là pour se le rassurer
sur son élocution ou pas
[Rires]
ce qui est incroyable compliqué hein
c'est très très fort c'est compliqué il
y a quelques jours Cyril Guillaume
Genton a pris un peu trop la défense
d'amis à l'antenne regarde aussi
c'est vrai ça t'a choqué qu'elle soit au
concert de Jay-Z bah franchement fait sa
vie mais bon en ce moment c'est pas trop
le moment quoi pas mal donc elle a un
regard sur l'actuaire
il a raison
Guillaume Genton je ne vais pas vous la
prendre vous qui nous regardez aux
alentours de 19h20 c'est un énorme Charo
Guillaume
c'était sorti les mots les chacals
autour de cette table qui ont voulu lui
fracasser son bail que j'entends un beau
lui draguer Anissa mais il n'a pas été
aidé c'est le fait de ton pote de la
semaine
le fuck ton pote de la semaine
[Musique]
pour aller chiner sa proie mais problème
Jean-Mi est déjà sur le dos
[Musique]
ça va bien se passer
[Applaudissements]
on avance on est dessus avec les équipes
avec les équipes
[Rires]
partir du PSG mais si moi je partais de
ton slip ça fait plus de dégâts non mais
sans déconner qu'est-ce que je fais
comme passe des amis
quand même pas du tout
les femmes qui viennent à lui comme le
Big Mac les victimes de son succès en
fait c'est les filles violentes et comme
vous vous êtes droit comme industrie
vous pouvez dépassez tout il y a rien de
sexisme dans tout ça tu leur s'il a un
autre
qui marque des buts Cyril après
guillaume est un sentimental c'est un
peu c'est un romantique je peux vous
dire et Guillaume cherche l'amour pour
l'instant c'est que Guillaume qui est
très beau et très jeune mais vous mettez
Guillaume et Jean-Mi en boîte je vous
promets que c'est Jean-Mi qui est repart
avec la plus jolie fille parce que
pourquoi parce qu'il y a pas de lumière
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
moi je pense que vous mettez Mathieu
Guillaume et Jean-Mi dans la même boîte
et ben c'est Mathieu qui repart avec la
plus belle fille aussi
parce que toi tu es un petit malin toi
alors je sais que tu attends on m'a dit
des choses
sur ma caisse ou quoi c'est interdit
sur ton cas j'ai bien entendu
sur ton lundi je reçois une chatte que
j'ai acheté
une femme
absolument je reçois lundi je vais la
chercher là
elle a dit moi ta chatte
elle est magnifique qu'est-ce qu'elle
est belle ta chatte très belle
mais ta chatte est magnifique
[Rires]
alors j'ai dit je pense que j'ai appelé
Claudia Claudia
Claudia comme Claudia Cardinale c'est
très
Chica cardinale Claudia
tu veux que j'appelle comment comme la
meuf qui vendait
elle est magnifique elle est magnifique
dis-moi
ta chatte ici ouais mais c'est un
panique parce que j'étais chez Bricorama
il faut acheter de la maison ce qu'il
faut mettre dedans alors c'est pas une
maison
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que tu fais toi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le prochain match
[Rires]
et très court mais il va vous plaire il
va vous plaire Cyril puisque c'est la
révélation masculine de la semaine vous
allez kiffer Siri
révélation masculine de la semaine
[Musique]
non je me casse et
[Applaudissements]
toi son père
son anniversaire
la grille
il aime bien manger
sur une séquence cette semaine
Jean-Marc Jean-Marc Guinel
un chanteur des années 80
allez on écoute tout de suite Jean-Marc
Guinel avec
tape-moi sur le popotin
le problème c'est un peu moins sur le
popotin
et tape
tape c'est le problème avec Cyril quand
il tient un tube on ne peut plus on ne
peut plus l'arrêter on est cuit alors là
vous avez vu deux minutes mais imaginez
pendant les pubs et pendant les magnétos
c'était un enfer c'est l'obsccessible de
la semaine
l'obsessif de la semaine
[Musique]
tape tape sur popotin sur le popotin
retenez bien cette phrase parce que vous
allez en bouffer
Thomas
Guinel bon elle est un petit point avec
les équipes on repasse en mode boulot
boulot Cyril
ça peut-être
tape sur le popotin voilà de toute
évidence on a affaire à force un nez qui
veut même entraîner le public dans sa
chute
un peu tard
sur le popotin bon la série vous aime
bien mais vous commencez un peu à nous
casser les couilles quand même
chaud chaud
Marcinelle tape sur le popotin
ah ouais donc ça part même en Reichmann
là j'en peux plus faut vraiment
l'arrêter peut-être
une chronique à faire Cyril
j'embarquement
bon c'est fini heureusement heureusement
on a échappé à la Corée
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Jean-Marc Guinel DJ résidant Jean-Marc
est-ce qu'on peut avoir un visuel de ce
Jean-Marc Guinel à quoi il ressemble
emmène-moi les perruques
François on a décidé de faire un tube et
c'est vous qui allez décider tu sais où
qu'elle ait décidé de la teter de
Jean-Marc Guinet donc Jean-Marc Guinel
euh alors je vais vous allez décider
chez vous de la tenter de Jean-Marc
Guinel je vais vous dire je vais vous
donner plusieurs
[Rires]
choisissez chez vous à quoi ressemble
[Applaudissements]
pas mal mais c'est pas mal c'est pas mal
c'est pas mal attention j'en essaie un
autre plus tu vois plus la roquette tu
vois
ça a l'air pas mal ça a l'air pas mal
[Rires]
ça a l'air pas mal
ce soir
[Rires]
Jean-Pierre
Françoise avant de faire entrer les
danseuses
oui oui sachez que
à cartonné sur les plateformes et les
numéros 1 et il y a un clip qui est
sorti avec le bureau
c'est lui ça
il est bien il y a un truc là
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas mal c'est pas mal c'est pas
mal lequel validez-vous alors
ça c'est parti musique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sur le popotin
le
[Applaudissements]
sur le papa
[Musique]
de papa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chanter danser en fait merci pour la
discrétion
de luxe ah c'est pas Jean
s
sur le popotin
assez vite danseuse qu'est-ce que ça
fait d'être la star de cet été tu sais
que je suis en plus je te soupçonne de
créer un clip tout ça ça me fait très
très peur
c'est ce qu'on appelle la Genèse
au sommet vous savez qu'on a été je
crois qu'on a été disque de platine avec
Sébastien patoche non et je pense que
tape tape sur le popotin va être le tube
de l'été
vous avez l'entendre à Mykonos à Ibiza à
Saint-Tropez dans les fin fonds
aujourd'hui c'est une famille discrète
tranquille maintenant je veux bien jouer
le jeu rempli Ton père
il n'y a plus qu'un seul et unique
Jean-Marc Guinel il est devant toi
[Applaudissements]
jamais je suis pas ton père c'est
Jean-Marc c'est un personnage
il existe et est-ce que vous êtes prêt
pour la tournée de cet été non mais
c'est vrai
est-ce que vous êtes chaud pour une
tournée
[Applaudissements]
c'est reparti musique
sur le drapeau
[Applaudissements]
capitale sur le popotin regarde
sur la table
[Applaudissements]
sur le drapeau
[Musique]